the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi everybody welcome back to class a lot
to cover today so I'm just going to get
right to it so you may remember at the
end of last lecture I talked about the
empirical rule and said that there were
a couple of assumptions underlying it
that one is the mean estimation error is
zero and second that the distribution of
errors will be normally distributed
I didn't probably mention at the time
but we often call this distribution
Gaussian after the astronomer carl gauss
and it looks like that normal
distributions are very easy to generate
in Python and the little example here of
generating not a real normal
distribution but a discrete
approximation of one and the thing to
really notice about it here is this line
random gauss so that's a built-in
function of the random library the first
argument is the mean and the second
argument is the standard deviation or mu
and sigma as usually called every time I
call that I will get a different or
usually a different random value drawn
from a Gaussian with the mean in this
case of zero and a standard deviation of
100 I'm then going to produce a plot of
those so you can see what it looks like
and I'm going to do that using some
things we haven't seen before so first
of all we've seen histograms so pylab
pylab dot hist produces a histogram bins
tells us how many dins we want in the
histogram I said we want a hundred the
default is 10 dist is the values that
we'll use for it and then this is
something we haven't seen
for weights weights is a keyword
argument so normally when we produce a
histogram we take all of the values the
minimum to the maximum and in this case
we would divide them into a hundred bins
because I said bins equals 100 and then
we would for every so the first bin
might be well let's say we only had
values ranging from zero to 100 the
first bin would be all the zeros all the
ones up to all the 99s and it weights
each value in the bin by one so if the
bin had ten values falling in it the
y-axis would be a 10 if the bin had 50
values falling in it the y axis would go
up to 50 you can tell it how much you
want to weight each bin that the
elements in the bins and say no I don't
want them each to count as one I want
them to count as a half or a quarter
that will change the y axis so that's
what I've done here what I've said is
I've created a list and I want to say
for each of the bins in this case I'm
going to give them way each of them the
same way the weight is going to be 1
over the number of samples I'm
multiplying it by the Len of dist that
will be how many items I have and that
will tell me how much each one is being
weighted so for example if I have say a
thousand items I could give a thousand
values and say I want this item weighted
by 1 and I want this item over here
weighted by 12 or 1/2 we rarely do that
usually we want is to give each item the
same weight
so why would I want it not to be waited
at just 1 because I want my y-axis to be
more easily interpreted as essentially
give me the fraction of the values that
fell in that bin and that's what I'm
doing here the other new thing I'm doing
here is the plotting commands including
pylab dot hist many of them return
values usually I just ignore that value
and we just say pylab dot plot or pylab
dot hist Here I am taking the value the
value in this case for a histogram is a
tuple of length two the first element is
a list or an array giving me how many
items are in each bin and the second is
the patches used to produce the
beautiful pictures we're used to seeing
so here what I'm going to do is take
this value so that I can do this at the
end now why would I want to look at the
fraction within approximately 200 of the
mean what is that going to correspond to
in this case well if I divide 200 by 2 I
get 100 which happens to be the standard
deviation so in this case what I'm going
to be looking at is what fraction of the
values fall within two standard
deviations of the mean kind of a check
on the empirical rule right all right
when I run the code I get this so it is
a discrete approximation to the
probability density function you'll
notice unlike the previous picture I
showed you which was nice and smooth
this is jaggedy you would expect it to
be and
again you can see it's very nice that
the the peak is what we said the mean
should be zero
and then it falls off and indeed
slightly more than 95% fall within two
standard deviations of the mean not even
surprised that it's a little bit more
than 95% because remember the magic
number is 1.96 not two but since this is
only a finite sample I only want it to
be around 95 I'm not going to worry too
much whether it's bigger or smaller all
right so random dot Gauss does a nice
job of love giving us Gaussian values we
plotted them and now you can see that
I've got the relative frequency that's
why I see fractions on the y-axis rather
than counts and that was because of the
way I use the weights command all right
let's return to PDFs so as we said last
time distributions can be defined by
probability density functions that gives
us the probability of some random
variable lying between two values it
defines a curve where the values in the
x-axis lie between the minimum and
maximum values of the variable and it's
the area under the curve and we'll come
back to this between those two points
that give us the probability of an
example of falling in that range so now
let's look at it for a normal
distribution you may recall from the
last lecture this rather exotic-looking
formula which defines a PDF for a normal
distribution and here's some code that
says straightforward and implementation
as one could imagine of this this
formula okay so that now is a value that
given mu and a Sigma and an X give
to me the ex associated with that mu and
Sigma okay and you'll notice there's
nothing random about this alright it is
giving me the value now let's go down
here and I'm going to for a set of X's
get the set of Y's corresponding to that
and then plot it I'm going to set new to
0 and Sigma 2 1 is so-called standard
normal distribution and I'm going to
look at the distribution from minus 4 to
4 nothing magic about that other than as
you'll see it's kind of a place where it
asymptotes near zero so while X is less
than 4 I'll get the x value I'll get the
Y value corresponding to that X by
calling Gaussian increment X by 0.05 and
do that until I'm done and then simply
I'll plot the X values against the Y
values and throw a title on it using
pylab title all right code makes sense
well this is where I got that beautiful
picture we've looked at before when I
plotted here
it actually looks actually quite smooth
it's not it's really connecting a bunch
of tiny little lines but I made the
points close enough together that it
looks at least here smooth it at this
resolution so we know what the values
are on the x axis are those are the
values I happen to want to look at from
minus 4 to 4 what are the values on the
y-axis
we kind of would like to interpret them
as probabilities right but we could be
pretty suspicious about that and that if
we take this one point that's up here we
say the probability of that single point
is 0.4 well that doesn't make any sense
because in fact we know the probability
of any particular point is 0 in some
sense right so furthermore if I chose a
different value for Sigma I can actually
get this to go bigger than 1 on the
y-axis so if you take Sigma to be say
point 1
I think the y-axis goes up to something
like 40 so we know we don't have
probabilities in the range 40 so if
these aren't probabilities what are they
what are the Y values well not too
surprising since I claimed this was a
probability density function their
densities or what's the density if this
makes sense I'll say it then I'll try
and explain it it's a derivative of the
cumulative distribution function now why
are we talking about derivatives in the
first place well remember what we're
trying to say if we want to say ask
what's the probability of a value
falling between here and here we claimed
that that was going to be the area under
this curve write the integral as you
know from 1801 there's a very clear
relationship between derivatives and
integrals and so if we interpret each of
these points as a derivative in some
sense the slope here then we can look at
this as the area just by integrating
under there so to interpret a PDF we
always do it Matt the Matt
luckily actually I do it just by looking
at it but the only really interesting
mathematical questions to ask have to do
with area once we have the area we can
then talk about the probabilities of
some value falling within a region of
the curve so what's interesting here is
not the numbers of per se on the y axis
but the shape of the curve because those
numbers have to be related to the
numbers on the x axis DX dy right we're
looking at derivatives alright so now we
have to talk about integration I promise
you only hear about it for another few
minutes then we'll leave the topic so I
mentioned before sigh pi is a library
that contains a lot of useful
mathematical functions one of them is
integrate quad
well the integrate part is obvious it
means integration quad is telling you
the algorithm it's using to do the
integration all of these integrals are
going to be actual approximations to the
real integral pylab is our side pi is
not doing some clever mathematics get an
analytical solution it's using a
numerical technique to approximate the
integral and the one huge here happens
to be called quadrature it doesn't
matter all right you can pass it up to
four arguments you must pass it the
function to be integrated that makes
sense
a number representing the lower limit of
the integration you need to give it that
number representing the upper limit you
need to give it that and then the fourth
argument is a tuple supplying all values
for the arguments to be except the first
of the function you're integrating I'll
show you an example of that on the next
slide and we'll see that it returns
tuple an approximation to the result
what it thinks the integral is and an
estimate of how much error there might
be in that one will ignore the error for
the moment all right let's look at the
code so we start by importing Sipe I
integrate that gives us all the
different integration methods I'm not
going to show you the code for Gaussian
since I showed it to you a couple of
minutes ago but I wanted you to remember
that takes three arguments X mu and
Sigma because when we get down here to
the integration we'll pass it the
function Gaussian and then the values
that we want to integrate over so those
will be the values that X can take upon
and that will change as we go from mu
minus the number of standard deviation
of x sigma to MU plus the number of
standard deviations ties times Sigma and
then this is the optional fourth
argument the tuple mu and Sigma why do I
need to pass that in because Gaussian is
a ternary argument or function it takes
three values and I'm going to integrate
over values of X so I have to fix mu and
Sigma two constants which is what I'm
doing down here and then I'll take the
zeroth value which is its estimate of
the integral alright so that's the new
thing the rest of the code is all stuff
you've seen for T and range number of
trials I'm going to choose a random u
between minus ten and ten and a random
Sigma between one and ten doesn't matter
what those constants are and then for
the number of standard deviations in one
1.96
and three I'm going to integrate
Gaussian over that range and then we're
just going to see how many of them are
fall within that range in some sense
what we're doing is we're checking the
empirical rule we're saying take a
Gaussian I don't care what you and Sigma
are doesn't matter the empirical rule
will still hold I think but we're just
checking it here okay well here are the
results so from rule equals nine and
Sigma equals six happen to choose those
we'll see the fraction within one
fraction point one point nine six and
three and so for these random Meuse and
Sigma's you can see that all women you
can set them to whatever you want when
you get your hands on the code
essentially what we have is whoops the
empirical rule actually works one of
those beautiful cases where you can test
the theory and see that the theory
really is sound so there we go
so why am I making such a big deal of
normal distributions they have lots of
nice mathematical properties some of
which we've already talked about but all
that would be irrelevant if we didn't
see them the good news is they're all
over the place I've just taken a few
here up here we'll see SAT scores
I would never show that to high school
students but or GRE
to you guys but you can see that they're
amazingly well distributed as along a
normal distribution on down here this is
plotting a percent change in oil prices
and again we see something very close to
a normal distribution and here is just
looking at heights of men and women and
again they clearly look very normal
so it's really quite impressive how
often they occur but not everything is
normal so we saw that the empirical rule
works for normal distributions I just
don't say I proved it for you i
illustrated it for you with a bunch of
examples but are the outcomes of the
spins of a roulette wheel normal no
they're totally uniform right everything
is equally probable four six and eleven
thirteen double zero if you're in Las
Vegas they're all equally probable so if
I plotted those I basically just get a
straight line with everything at one
over however many pockets there are so
in that case why does the empirical rule
work we saw that we were doing some
estimates about returns and we use the
empirical rule we checked it and by
George it was telling us the truth and
the reason is because we're not
reasoning about a single spin of the
wheel but about the mean of a set of
spins so if you think about it what we
were reasoning about was the return of
bedding if we look at one spin well
let's say we bet $1 the return is either
minus one because we've lost our dollar
or if we get lucky in our pocket happens
to come up it was 36 I think were 35 I
forget which okay but that's all so if
we plotted a histogram we would see a
huge peak at -1 and a little bump here
at 36 and nothing in the middle
clearly not a normal distribution
but what we're reasoning about is not
the return of a single spin but the
return of many spins if we played a
thousand spins what is our expected
return as soon as we end up reasoning
not about a single event but about the
mean of something we can apply something
called the central limit theorem and
here it is it's actually for something
so important very simple it says that
given a sufficiently large sample Isle
of terms like sufficiently large but
will later put a little meat on that the
following three things are true the
means of the samples in a set of samples
the so called sample means will be
approximately normally distributed so
that says if I take a sample and
remember a sample might have will have
multiple examples so just to remind
people a population is a set of examples
a sample is a subset of the population
so it too is a set of examples right
typically if this set is sufficiently
large certainly one is not sufficiently
large then it will be the case that the
mean of the means so I take the mean of
each sample and then I can now plot all
of those means or take the mean of those
right and they'll be normally
distributed
furthermore this distribution will have
a mean that is close to the mean of the
population the mean of the means will be
close to the mean of the population and
the variance of the sample means will be
close to the variance of the population
divided by the sample size this is
really amazing that this is true and
dramatically useful so to get some
insight let's check it to do that
postulate that we have this kind of
miraculous die so instead of a die that
when you roll it you get a number one
two three four five or six
this particular die is continuous it
gives you a real number between zero and
five or maybe it's between one and six
okay so it's a continuous die what we're
going to do is roll it a lot of times
we're going to say how many die and then
how many times are we going to roll that
number of die so the number of die will
be the sample size number of dice will
be the sample size and then we'll take a
bunch of samples which I'm calling
number of rolls and then we'll plot it
and I'm just saying choosing some bins
and some colors and some style and
various other things just to show you
how we use the keyword arguments so for
actually I said num rolls is is the
number of trials but it isn't quite fat
because I'm going to get the number of
trials by dividing the number of rolls
by the number of dice so if I have more
dice I get to have fewer samples
more dice per sample all right then
we'll just do it so it will be between 0
& 5 because random dot random returns a
number between 0 & 1
and I'm multiplying it by 5 and then
we'll look at the means and we'll plot
it all again we're playing games with
weights just to make the plot a little
easier to read and here's what we get if
we roll one die the mean is very close
to 2.5 well that's certainly what you'd
expect right it's some random number
between 0 & 5 2.5 is a pretty good guess
as to what it should average and it has
a standard deviation of 1 point 4 4
that's a little harder to guess that
that's what it would be but you could
figure it out a little math or as I did
here with the simulation but now if I
roll 50 dice
well again the mean is close to 2.5 it's
what you'd expect right I roll 50 dice I
get the mean value of those 50 but look
how much smaller the standard deviation
is more importantly what we see here is
that if we look at the value the
probability is flat for all possible
values between 0 & 5 for a single die
but if we look at the distribution for
the means it's not quite Gaussian but
it's pretty close why is it not Gaussian
well I didn't do it an infinite number
of times did it quite a few but not an
infinite number enough that you didn't
want to sit here while it ran
but you can see the amazing thing here
that when I go from looking at one to
looking at the mean of 50 suddenly I
have a normal distribution and that
means that I can bring to bear on the
problem the central limit theorem we can
try it for roulette again I'm not going
to make you sit through a million trials
of 200 spins each I'll do it only for
fair roulette and again this is a very
simple simulation and we'll see what we
get
and what we see is it's not quite normal
again but it definitely has that shape
now it's going to be a little bit
strange because I can't lose more than
one right if I'm betting one so it will
never be quite normal right because it's
going to be truncated down on the left
side whereas the tail can be arbitrarily
long so again we'll mathematically it
can't be normal but it's close enough in
the main region where most of the values
lie that we can get away with applying
the empirical rule and looking at
answers and indeed as we saw it does
work so what's the moral here it doesn't
matter what the shape of the
distribution of the original values
happen to be if we're trying to estimate
the mean using samples that are
sufficiently large the CLT will allow us
to use the empirical rule when computing
confidence intervals
even if we go back and look at this
anomaly over on the left what do you
think would happen if I instead of had
200 had say a thousand what's the
probability of the average return being
minus one of a thousand bets much
smaller right than for a hundred bets to
lose a thousand times in a row is pretty
unlikely so to get all the way to the
left is going to be less likely and
therefore the thing will start looking
more and more normal as the samples get
bigger all right and so we can use the
CLT to justify using the empirical rule
when we compute confidence intervals all
right I want to look at one more example
in detail this is kind of an interesting
one you might think that randomness is
of no use for say finding the value of
pi because there's nothing random about
that similarly you might think that
randomness was of no use in integrating
a function but in fact the way those
numerical algorithms work is they use
randomness what you're about to see is
that randomness and indeed things
related to Monte Carlo simulations can
be enormous ly useful even when you're
computing something that is inherently
not random like the value at pi here and
we won't ask you to remember that many
digits on the quiz in the exam all right
so what's pi well people have known
about pi for thousands and thousands of
years and what people knew was that
there was some constant we'll call it pi
it wasn't always called that such that
it was equal to the circumference of a
circle divided by the diameter and
furthermore the area was going to be pi
r-squared people knew that way back to
the Babylonians and Egyptians
what they didn't know is what that value
was the earliest-known estimate of Pi
was by the Egyptians on something called
the Rhind papyrus pictured here and they
estimated PI to be 4 times 8 over 9
squared or 3.16 not so bad about 1100
years later
later an estimate of Pi appeared in the
Bible King 723 didn't say pi is but it
described I think this was a
construction of King Solomon's Temple
he made a molten sea ten cubits from one
room to the other
it was round ie was a circle his height
was five cubits and a line of thirty
cubits did compass it round about well
if you do the arithmetic what does this
imply the value of pi to be three and
I'm sure that's what Mike Pence thinks
it is
about about 300 years later Archimedes
did a better job of it he estimated PI
by constructing a 96 sided polygon
there's a picture of one it looks a lot
like a circle on the left is one with
fewer sides and what he did is he then
since it was a polygon he knew how to
compute its area or circumference and he
just counted things up and he said well
pi is somewhere between 223 over 71 and
22 over 7 and that turns out to actually
if you look take the average of that be
a really good estimate two thousand
years after Archimedes the French
mathematicians Buffon and Laplace
proposed finding the value of pi using
what we would today call a Monte Carlo
simulation they did not have a computer
to execute this on so what they proposed
started with this mathematics they took
a circle and inscribed it in a square
the square of 2 / 2 units of whatever it
is per side and therefore we know that
the area of the square is 2 times 2 or 4
we know that the area of the circle is
PI R squared and since we know that R is
1 because that's the square it's
inscribed in we know that the area of
the circle is exactly PI what befall
then proposed was dropping a bunch of
needles at random you know kind of like
when Professor Grimson was sorting
things and seeing where they land some
would land in the square but not in the
circle some would land in the circle you
would ignore any that landed outside the
square and then they said well since
they're falling at random
the ratio of the needles in the circle
to needles in the square should exactly
equal the area of the square over the
area of the circle exactly if you did an
infinite number of needles that makes
sense now
given that you can do some algebra and
solve for the area of the circle and say
it has to be the area of the square
times the number of needles in the
circle divided by the needles in the
square and since we know that the area
of the circle is PI that tells us that
pi is going to equal 4 times a needles
in the circle that's 4 is the area of
the square divided by the number of
needles in the square and so the
argument was you can just drop a bunch
of these needles see where they land add
them up and from that you would
magically now know the actual value of
pi well we try to simulation one year in
class but rather than using needles we
had an archer and we blindfolded him so
he would shoot arrows at random and we
would see how many see where they ended
up there's a video of this here if you
want to see it I'm going to play only
the very end of the video which
describes the results
maybe we should just use Python to build
a Monte Carlo simulation instead so
that's what happened after it was all
over Anna came up and gave me some sound
advice yeah I was very proud of that
particular shot with the Apple
I had hoped the student would put it on
his or her head but no one volunteered
that was not done blindfolded any rate
so here's the simulation so first we
have throwing the needles for needles
and range one to number of needles plus
one we're going to choose at random X a
random Y and we're going to see whether
or not it's in the circle and there
we'll use the Pythagorean theorem to
tell us that all right and we'll just do
this and then we're going to return
exactly the formula we saw in the
previous slide now comes an interesting
part we need to get an estimate so we
start with the number of needles and the
number of trials for t and range number
of trials we'll get a guess
by throwing number of needles and then
we'll append that guess to our list of
estimates we'll then compute the
standard deviation get the current
estimate which will be the sum of the
estimates divided by the Len of the
estimates just the mean of the estimates
and then we'll print it all right so
given a number of needles and a number
of trials we'll estimate pi and we'll
give you the standard deviation of that
estimate however to do that within a
certain precision I'm going to have yet
another loop and I'm showing you this
because we often structure simulations
this way
so what I'm have here is well the number
of trials which is not so interesting
but the precision I'm saying I would
like to know the value of pi' and I
would like to have good reason to
believe that the value give me is within
point zero five in this case of the true
value okay or maybe more precisely I
would like to know with a confidence of
95% that the true value is within a
certain range so what this is going to
do is it's just going to I should
probably use 1.96 instead of two but oh
well it's just going to keep increasing
the number of needles doubling the
number of needles until it's confident
about the estimate they're confident
enough all right so this is a very
common thing we don't know how many
needles we should need so let's just
start with some small number and we'll
keep going until we're good all right
what happens when we run it well we
start with some estimates that when we
had a thousand needles it told us that
pi was three point one four eight and
standard deviation was 0.04 seven etc so
a couple of things to notice one are my
estimates of Pi getting monotonically
better you'd like to think as I add more
needles my estimates are getting more
accurate so that's question one are they
getting more accurate not monotonically
right if we look at it where where are
they getting worse so let's see three
all right three point one four eight
well three point one three is already
worse right
so I double the number of needles and I
get a worse estimate now the trend is
good right by the time I get here I've
got a pretty good estimate so overall as
I look at larger samples a bigger subset
of the population my estimates are
trending towards better but not every
time on the other hand let's look at the
standard deviations what we see here is
that the standard deviations are indeed
getting monotonically better now there's
nothing mathematical guaranteeing that
right because there is randomness here
but I'm increasing the number of needles
by so much that it kind of overrides the
bad luck of maybe getting a bad random
set and we see those are getting better
so the important thing to see here is
not that I happen to get a better
estimate but that I know more about the
accident I can have more confidence in
the estimate because it's closing in on
it so the moral here is it's not
sufficient to produce a good answer I've
said this before we need to have reason
to believe that it is close to the right
answer so in this case I'm using the
standard deviation and say given that
it's gotten quite small now two times
point a 1.96 times 0.002 is indeed a
small number I could make it smaller if
I wanted I believe that I have good
reason to believe I'm close to the right
value of pi everyone agree with that
that right
not quite actually it would be nice if
it were true but it isn't so let's look
at some things is it correct to state
that 95% of the time we run this
simulation we'll get an estimate of Pi
between these two values I don't expect
you to the arithmetic in your head but
the answer is yes so that is something
we believe is true by the math we've
been looking at for the last two
lectures next statement with the
probability of 0.95 the actual value of
pi is between these two things is that
true in fact if I were to say with a
probability of 1 the actual value is pi
is between those two values would it be
true yes so there are both true facts
however only the first of these can be
inferred from our simulation while the
second fact is true we can't infer it
from the simulation and to show you that
statistically valid is not the same as
true we'll look at this I've introduced
a bug in my simulation I've replaced the
four that we saw we needed by 2 now easy
kind of mistake to make and now we go to
the code
well what do you think will happen if we
go to the code run it will try it will
go down here to the code we'll make that
a two
and what you'll see is it runs is that
once again we're getting very nice
confidence intervals but totally bogus
values of pi all right so the statistics
can tell us something about how
reproducible our simulation is but not
whether the simulation is an actually
accurate model of reality so what do you
need to do you need to do something like
a sanity check so here you might look at
a polygon and say well clearly that's a
totally wrong number something is wrong
with my code okay
so just to wrap up what we've shown is a
way to find pi this is a generally
useful technique to estimate the area of
any region R you pick an enclosing
region call it e such that it's easy to
estimate the area of E and R lies within
it pick some random sets of points
within E let F be the fraction and fall
within R multiply e by F and you're done
so this for example is a very common way
to do integration I promised you we'd
talk about integration so here's a sine
of X if I want to integrate the sine of
X over some region as done here all I
need to do is pick a bunch of random
points red and black in this case and
look at the ratio of one to the other so
showing how we can use randomness to
again compute something that is not
inherently random this is a trick people
use over and over and over again when
confronted with some
tuition where it's not easy to solve for
things mathematically you just do a
simulation and if you do it right you
get a very good answer all right we will
move on to a different topic on
Wednesday
you